Loads of people have talked about the
International Standard Cup of Tea.
And there are hundreds of
clickbait articles describing it,
or ranting about how it's
the wrong way to make tea,
and there are lengthy infographics videos
talking about it.
But, as far as I can tell,
no-one has actually made a
Standard Cup of Tea for the internet before.
And there are a couple of reasons for that:
one, you have to either
buy a copy of the standard
or visit a library that subscribes to the
Standards online
so you can write down the details,
and two, it requires specialist equipment.
Most people in Britain make their tea by putting
a teabag in a mug
and then pouring boiling water on it.
If you want to be fancy,
then you take a pre-warmed teapot,
and you put some loose-leaf tea in it,
like this stuff,
and then you brew the tea in there,
and then you pour the results
through a strainer into a cup.
It's... it's fancy.
But the standard, ISO 3103,
doesn't ask for any of that.
Instead, it uses a bit of equipment that most
people won't even have heard of:
which is a Professional Tea Tasting Set.
Now, the standard describes it
in more technical terms,
diagrams, and requirements of construction
and weight and size and volume,
but fortunately I could just buy a set that
matched the standard.
And the instructions for it are
actually pretty simple:
you measure out 2g of tea per 100ml of water,
plus or minus 2%.
So for this, that means 2.8g,
plus or minus .05g,
which I worked out in advance because it took
it ages to get it that precise.
And then you combine that with either local or
standardised water depending on what you're testing,
by filling this little mug to the bottom of
those serrations.
Also, you let it steep for six minutes, which
seems a bit long, but hey, that's the standard.
Once your six minutes are up, you separate
the 'liquor', as it's called, from the tea leaves
by pouring it through the little serrations here
into this cup.
Let's see if I can do it...
No, I can't.
But close enough.
They say that if you're adding milk,
you should put it in first,
but this is green tea, so I'm not getting
involved in that debate.
You drain it through there, most of the leaves
stay in the cup,
and once it's drained, you can
inspect the tea leaves.
And then you drink it not from the traditional
cup, but from the bowl.
There is a separate standard, ISO 1839, on
how you actually sample it, and what you report.
And it tastes, er...
(slurps)
Tastes okay.
It's just okay.
Because the standard isn't meant to make the
perfect cup of tea,
or the most British cup of tea.
Every time the fact that there's a Standard
for Tea does the rounds of the internet,
loads of people misunderstand it as being
prescriptive,
and saying "everyone should make
their tea this way",
and they really shouldn't.
ISO 3103 is meant to make an okay
but reproducible cup of tea.
It sets out instructions so that,
whoever and wherever you are,
you can create the same cup of tea as
someone else in another time and place.
For regular tea at home?
Make it however you want.
Stick a teabag in a mug,
put the milk in first or last.
Use fancy china if you want.
Make your tea days in advance and then
warm it up again in the microwave.
Don't... don't do that.
But it doesn't matter.
There is no perfect cup of tea:
there's only the right one for you.
This here? This isn't perfect,
it definitely isn't perfect,
but as far as I can tell,
this is the first International Standard
Cup of Tea on the internet.
(slurps)
I don't actually like tea.